Hello, Avery. What's up, bro? So,
actually, I had an objection against
Christianity. Could I present it? The
topic is that Islam is untrustworthy.
Yeah, but you know, I messaged you a few
days ago. I asked you if I could come up
with an objection. If that's possible,
you told me you're going to be live on
Wednesday and Monday, so if we could
make it an exception. All right. So,
let's do this. Let's deal with the topic
first and then after we finish the
topic, you can bring up your objection.
Look, to be honest, I'm not educated on
Islam, you know. I just had an
objection. No, not to be honest. I just
had an objection that I was wondering
about if I could come and ask you about
it if that is possible. And you're a
Muslim. Well, not really. I'm in
between. So, you said you're what? I'm
in between. You know, I'm not really
sure of my faith, but yeah, I could say
I'm a Muslim, but not really. So, you're
you're a Muslim, but not really. It's
either you are or you're not. Well, I'm
shaking right now. I'm kind of an
agnostic person. Okay. So, can I present
my objection? Sure. What's your
objection? Okay. Is each person of the
Trinity God? Before we do this, Yeah. Do
you do you do you already know what I
believe as a Christian or the Trinity?
Yeah. The Trinity Each person of the
Trinity is God, but they're one essence.
They're one essence, three distinct
persons. So, get straight to your
objection. Let's let's Okay. So, getting
straight to my objection that uh the
three persons could not be the same
through God. And the three persons could
not be equally God if only one person
with Trinity is God. Like John 5:44, uh
Jesus calls the father explicitly the
one and only God. So they could not be
each person could not be God if the
father is the one and only God. You said
John 5:44. Yeah. John 5:44. What does it
say? How can you believe when you accept
glory from one another and not see glory
from the one and only God? You know the
New Revised Standard Version, it
translates this and do not All right.
Sure. Slowly, slowly, slowly. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. He says talking to the
people that you seek glory from men but
not from the one and only God. Yeah. And
where does this negate Jesus as being
God? Yeah. Because he calls the father
the one and only God. How does that
negate Jesus being God as well? Yeah.
Because the father could not be a lone
God. Because if he is a lone God, then
that actually removes the other two
person. It doesn't say it doesn't say
that the father alone. No, actually it
does say in the Greek monom. Yeah. Mono
which means alone only. Wait wait wait
hold on a second. Only what? What? What
is what is the only is it? Okay. Wait a
second. Okay. So actually the the the
masculine singular adjective which is
monon is lexically defined defined in
page 739 in the Greek English lexicon of
the New Testament as the only entity in
a class. Only one. What's your what's
your Okay. Um Muhammad. My name is
Muhammad. Muhammad. Hold on. I need I
need you to listen to what I'm asking.
Okay. What does the word only say? Is it
saying that only the father is God or?
Yes, only the father is God. Because if
he's the one only God, okay, you're
referring to the father. Let me read
this again. How can you believe when you
receive glory from one another and do
not seek glory that comes from the only
God? Okay. Where does it say that the
father alone is God? Yeah, because the
Greek word monon actually means alone.
Yeah. What is al alone? What what's
alone? Is it the father that's alone or
is it God alone? Yeah, father. He go to
the context. You would understand that
he was referring to the father. Just
specifically here it says only God, not
that the father alone. No, no, no. Read
the context. Read the context. I am I am
just Yeah, you could go one verse early.
Yeah, he was No, no. He was referring to
the God. Yeah, my friend RD sorry
Muhammad. Yeah. Talking about the word
that you brought. You tried to make an
argument that the word only here is or
Jesus says that the father alone is God.
Yes. Because according to the context.
Please hold on a second. Yeah. He
doesn't say that the father alone is
God. Is that clear? Is that can we agree
there? Cuz we can't agree. No, it does.
No. No, it does. No. No. According to
the context, the father alone is God.
Let me let me just do this really quick.
All right. It's on the It's on the
screen. Okay. Okay. Here we go. It's on
the screen now. I'm about to highlight
it. How can you believe when you receive
glory from one another and do not seek
the glory that comes from the only God
or the only the father alone who is God?
What does it say? Does it say the only
God? Actually, no. According to the
context, he was speaking about the
father. So then when he refers to God or
does it say only the father is God? No,
actually according to the to the
context, he's actually referring to the
father. Okay. Look, look. Okay, I'm I'm
giving you a chance. I'm giving you a
chance. I really wanted to bring your
objection. I'm giving you a chance to be
honest with the text. Yeah. Okay. Okay.
So, look. I I came Does it say that
Jesus says that only the father is God
or does it say where it has only
modifying God? No. Accord look my
argument is that according to the
context he's referring to the father.
Okay. Look, I'll give you this. Okay,
hold on. I I'll tell you something. I'll
give you this for the sake of an
argument and I'm going to change the
verse to Okay, look. All right. Sure.
Okay. Okay. I'll I'll grant you this.
I'll grant you this. I don't need I
don't need a granting. I need to know if
you could be honest with the text. All
right. Does it say only God or does it
say the father alone is God? Yeah,
according to the context, it's the
father who's the one and only.
All right. Let's go ahead and give
somebody else a try. Issa, how you
doing? I'm good. How about you? Pretty
good. Pretty good. Hey, I just saw I saw
you got married actually. I did. I did.
I'm happy for you. Thank you, bro.
You're welcome. I'm married as well. Oh,
how long? Since July. Been very nice.
Alhamdulillah. That's dope. So, I wanted
to This isn't anything about Bible or
Quran. I wanted to ask you on your
knowledge of Greek and Hebrew. Are you
able to understand them? I'm not a Greek
or Hebrew speaker. All right. That's
all. Okay. And one more thing. Um, what
do you think about your Palestinian
Christians? Are you okay with their
churches being bombed? Are you? Nope.
Good. Are you? Nope. Then why don't you
speak on it? Why do you not advocate for
their safety? How many times are you
going to create an account? I'm not
Ellie. How many times you going to
create an account? I'm on the other
side. You guys are weird, man. Wow. You
guys are so weird. You guys will make
the same account. You guys will make
this uh all these different accounts
desperate to get on my panel. Desperate.
I'm I promise you I've never seen this
before with people. I've never seen this
before other than in Islam, man. Other
than in Islam. I've never seen this
before. You got like Islam produces the
weirdest people I've ever known. I've
ever encountered. Weird, man. You guys
are weird. Obviously, there's some cool
ones among you, but man, you guys are
weird. I've never I've never seen this
before, but there it's just weird. How
you doing, man? How are you, brother?
I'm good. I'm good. Do you disagree? I
will ask you small question and I will
go out. Do you disagree, brother? What
do you mean? I have a topic on the
screen. Do you see it? Yeah, I see. Do
you disagree? I'm a Muslim. What that
mean? I'm Muslim. I believe in Allah.
So, you don't believe Jesus is God? I
believe he is the prophet and I follow
him. Why don't you believe he's God?
Because God can be a man. Really? Yeah.
Muhammad says that Allah is going to
show up in a shape that matches what you
imagine him to be. If you imagine Allah
Really? If you imagine Allah to be a
man, can't he come? He's can't he come
in the form of a man? Brother, who
created uh Jesus? Nobody. Nobody. Okay.
He have the mother. Yes. Okay. So, are
you gonna answer my question now? No.
Because I I just I just sent to Georgia.
You skipped my question. So, are you
gonna answer my question? No, I don't
skip it. You ask me, bro. I don't know
what you ask me. I asked you since
Muhammad teaches that Allah is going to
come in a shape that's closest to the
picture that you had in your mind about
him, closest to your imagination. If you
pictured, if you pictured him to be a
man, could he come in the shape of a
man? Find me that I will see it. Find
what? The hadith. Yeah, find someone.
It's Sahib Bukari 4581. Okay, I will go
now to see it and I will come back.
Okay, you don't have to. I already have
it. You want to just look at it? Okay.
Yeah, I want Okay. What is going on with
my computer? Bro, guys, am I glitching
on YouTube? Is it going in and out? Are
we good? You guys let me know on
YouTube. He's getting mad, right? I'm
not mad, brother. Okay, we're all good.
All right. Nice. All right. Yeah, my
computer is having some type of delay.
It's weird. My mouse is like tripping
out of me, bro. This is really getting
annoying, bro. Stuck for Come on. All
right.
4581. Then Allah, the Lord of the worlds
will come to them in a shape nearest to
the picture they had in their minds
about him. But you know how he will
come? He will come to them in a shape
that matches your your imagination.
That's how. But tell me how in a man or
what? If you imagine him to be a man,
he'll show up as a man. Y. So it does it
looks like Allah could become a man if
he wanted. Huh brother he will come like
a god not like a man brother. But if you
imagine him to be a man, if you pictured
in your mind for him to be a man, then
he'll come as a man, right? But he will
not come in this dunya, bro. In this
life, he will come in another one life.
Because when the finish, doesn't matter
what dunya you're talking about, Allah
can come as a man, right? If he wanted
to, right? Okay, brother. Okay, I
believe in you. Okay. You believe in No,
believe in Muhammad. Muhammad's right
when he says this, right? I believe in
him. I believe in all prophets. I don't
believe only in Muhammad. I can say I
believe only in Muhammad and not in
Jesus and oh yeah you don't believe in
Jesus yet. Who say that? Me. You. Mhm.
How I can say it? You don't believe in
Jesus. Yeah. You don't believe in Jesus.
You reject him. You okay? Okay. Yeah.
I'm okay. I will now ask you one
question. Okay. No. So, do you agree
that Allah can come as a man if he
wanted to? Yeah, he will come. He will
come Allah but not like a man. That's
what I asked. Can he do it? Can Where do
you see men? Listen. Where do you see in
this now? Men, you see, you say picture,
not like a man. Take care of yourself. A
picture. And thanks for coming. Watch
your head on the way out. You saying I'm
a little liar. Come prove me to be a
liar. If you think I'm lying, come prove
I'm lying, man. That's it. Come prove
that I'm lying. What's up with y'all? If
you think logic is lying, come prove
that logic is lying. What's up, bro? Yo.
Hello. Can you hear me? Yes. I have a
question for you. Yeah. What What's your
religion? Islam. Do you believe Islam is
reliable? Yeah. Would you trust a
religion that has corrupted scripture?
No. So then why do you trust Islam? I
mean, how is it corrupted? The Torah,
was it corrupted? Yes. I mean, well,
when it was revealed, no. But yeah, but
it it over time it got corrupted. Yes.
What about the gospel? Did that get
corrupted? Like what do you mean by
gospel? The gospel though. The go the
Yeah. Uh again at the time when it was
revealed? No. Over time. Yeah. All
right. So the Torah got corrupted. The
NGO got corrupted. What about the
Zubour? The Psalms. Did that get
corrupted? I don't think we have any
evidence on it. On what? On the Zub. So
you don't know if it was corrupted or
not? I mean, me personally, no. Okay,
I'll take that. So the Torah and the
Injil, they got corrupted and and these
were these were these are Islamic
scriptures, right? Yeah. So in within
Islam, you have two script two
scriptures that have been corrupted. But
you just said that you wouldn't trust a
religion that has corrupted scripture.
So why do you trust Islam? Islam doesn't
believe in the Bible today. Does is does
Islam believe in the Torah? I mean, it
believes in the Torah that was revealed
at the time of Moses, but not the Torah
we have today. Really? Yeah. When the
Quran says that it confirms that which
is with them, the Jews and the
Christians, what what do they have with
them in the seventh century in
Muhammad's time? Who's who's them? The
Jews and the Christians. What was the
verse? Chapter 2, verse 41. Yes. What
was it? It says, "Believe in what we
have sent down, confirming that which is
already with you." How do you know it's
referring to the Jews? Because the
context is about the Jews. I mean, how
how do you know that? Because I read it.
It talks about their covenant that they
had with God and they broke it and all
that kind of stuff. Yeah. But how does
it know it's it's not referring to the
previous revelations of the Quran?
Previous revelations of what? Of of the
Quran. Like that was in the first ayah
which was revealed. Because the Quran
says that it was sent down confirming
something that already exists. So the
Quran is not confirming itself. It's
confirming what was already there which
is revealed before the Torah and the
Gospel. Yeah, but it's it's confirming
what's already there. But how do you
know it's wasn't confirming the Do me a
favor. Go to chapter 4 verse 47. Okay.
Chapter 2 verse 4. Chapter 4. Chapter 4
verse 47. All
[Music]
right, I need to drop the link again.
And what happened, man? I thought I
already put that link in, though. Um,
where's my
live? How can I go to the beginning of
this chat? Let me do this. It won't let
me. Dang it. I got to drop the link
again. all over again. All right, here
you guys go. I thought I pinned it. My
bad for not pinning it. It makes sense
why uh we don't have any guests on
YouTube. Only have one in the beginning.
Muslim only. Brother, you there? Just to
let you know, I can't hear you if you're
uh off the app. Yeah. Hello. Right. You
see, did you see the verse? All right.
So, you see how it says it's addressing
the people of the book, the Jews and the
Christians. Mhm.
And says that the Quran is confirming
what they already have. But it says
revealed to you. And that's the Quran.
Uh-huh. Confirming what? Confirming.
Confirming. It says confirming your own
scriptures. Nice. That's that's cute and
all, but that's that's not what that
says. You're probably reading the the
clear Quran. The the clear Quran English
translation. The word is the it says
confirming what is with you. Yes. Again.
So, how do you know? It's not referring
to the Quran they had at that time. Are
you serious? Yeah. How long have you
been a Muslim? Well, all my life. All
your life. Have you ever read the Quran
before? Oh, yeah. You sure? Yeah. Who
are the people of the book? There were
many books which were revealed. Who are
the people of the book? Specific
category of people. You know, brother,
I'm so sorry. I I'm sorry. I can't I
can't I can't I can't I can't do this.
You you need to go read go read the
Quran before coming on the stage. Bro,
you haven't read the Quran. Okay. Wait,
wait. Could you just could you just see
could you just answer this? Uh you said
the verse was confirming Muslims, let me
just say this. Don't don't come up if
you don't if you haven't read your Quran
before. Um and not honestly like if you
want me to teach you Islam, I will. I'll
teach you I'll teach you the Quran. But
if you are coming with an honest, you
know, with honesty, if you come honestly
and you don't know, fine. If you're
coming like like that previous guy and
you don't know the Quran, don't don't
don't come on my stage, man. Don't do
it. Don't do it. Please, don't waste my
time. Respectfully, of course. Please,
please, please, cuz this is out of hand.
Goodness gracious. They going to think I
paid you to come up. Abri got has a
Muslim manufacturer in the back of his
house in the God logic office. He has a
machine that manufactures actors to
pretend to be Muslim. Goodness. Z
disappeared.